ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément en moins de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus tard ils ont
des choses à dire
la france humiliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
la france humiliée s'est montré ce qu'on
ne voit jamais
c'est
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'oise et
plus particulièrement à thourotte
[Musique]
bonjour sabine bonjour merci de nous
accueillir
alors on est masqué un masque ffp2 qu'on
finisse qu'ovide oblige
je vous félicite pour le port du masque
on s'est compliqué en ce moment à faire
porter le masque par les gens je porte
un masque vous portez le mas nous
portons le masque et nous nous contamine
ont pas et nous nous préservons tous
alors vous êtes infirmières libérales
oui on est chez vous ici dans votre tête
on n'est pas chez moi on est dans mon
cabinet dans votre cabinet c'est un
centre médical il ya plusieurs un
cabinet pluridisciplinaire avec un
kinésithérapeute runes pédicure une
sophrologue relaxologue bientôt nos
psychologues nous sommes propriétaires
de non lieu nous sommes complètement
autonome ou dépendant d'aucun organisme
et ben voilà c'est ainsi que des
paramédicaux il n'ya pas médecin
d'accord mais je vois que vous avez donc
alors voilà donc je fais partie du
collectif santé en danger parce que
actuellement les soignons ils sont hyper
remontées sont épuisés ça va pas du tout
eh ben on voudrait être reçu par le
président de la république ou le
ministre de la santé pour pouvoir
reparler tout ça un petit peu et à
remettre les choses à plat et il ya des
propositions qui ont été établies parce
que les soignants c'est une petite armée
puisqu'on était soldat des soldats
talons au front et on s'organise tout
seul on est autonome et on a plein de
propositions on voudrait que le
gouvernement nous écoute
en fait la santé on a un potentiel
énorme au niveau des soignants avec
d'une expertise des très bons médecins
des très bons soignants des très bonnes
infirmières des très bons étudiants
tous les gens sont très compétents et
bien formés mais on ne les utilise pas à
bon escient et on ne les écoute pas à
bon escient
quand ce genre de situation arrive ce ne
sont pas des administratifs qui doivent
diriger la france mais ce doit être ça
doit être des soignants vous avez encore
des problèmes d'équipement
ça va un tout petit peu mieux mais il
faut quand même se débrouiller quoi
système énormément il faut parce que la
profession des soignants c'est
l'anticipation et par rapport au travail
et surtout face aux situations de crise
ce n'est pas un dénominateur commun avec
le gouvernement d'accord parce qu'ils
ont rien anticipé du tout on est bien
d'accord elles nous ont surtout pas
écouter
donc ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que ben on nous écoute plus pour qu'on
puisse avoir le matériel que nous devons
avoir en cas de souci parce que quand il
ya un souci on doit être tout de suite à
l'action ça va il n'est pas bien là
alors j'entends bien tombera dessus
c'est un bien ton point voilà l'état des
belles 23 ces bonus donne mon sang rue
cérès et tu sais quoi c'est dommage que
j'ai pas une aide à voir parce que ça
aurait été vu quittant répliquait en
place caisse et je régal ton truc on
respire bien fort ça va pas
j'ai mis un petit parra main sur
tombeaux des saints
tu lui enlèvera tout à l'heure voilà
vous fait combien de d'actes comme ça
par jour en moyenne
en moyenne on est alors on est deux en
chine - qui travaillant tous les matins
c'est un cabinet de trois anciens bien
un mais on a toujours une qui en robes
ont fait un roulement il y en a eu 2 qui
travaillent le matin et le soir
et ça s'arrête jamais en fait du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre à domicile aussi
ah bah oui voilà beaucoup c'est quoi lui
ce dôme ici que le cabinet c'est quoi le
pourcentage 70 30 90 10 ah oui quand
même et on fait énormément de kilomètres
on est beaucoup chez les gens il ya
beaucoup de personnes âgées
voilà voilà voilà donc sabine on va où
le revoir au labo on va déposer le sens
au labo ok bah je vous suis un faux
courir un parce que je vois c'est bon je
suis entraîné à l'est
ouais donc les masques c'est quand même
elle est rationnée par le fait d'être le
gros souci qu'on a eus début octobre
c'est qu'ils ont ils ont arrêté la
distribution des masques
il ya certains endroits encore certaines
filles ont dû en du mal à récupérer
leurs stocks donc quand vous parlez des
masques sais quel type de masque les
deux on a toujours un stock de fpp2 est
un des masques chirurgicaux qui sont
attribués après la quantité allait pas
démentiel
sachant que logiquement on devrait on
devrait changer des masques beaucoup
plus souvent parce que c'est du coup on
est obligé de faire des économies et les
changer moins souvent
donc on se met encore en danger les
zones horreur les honoraires du losc
veut après les doigts ce sujet donc les
infirmières libérales ne sont pas riches
contrairement à ce que les gens pensent
la amy de base c'est-à-dire la cotation
que nous faisons pour un acte simple par
exemple une piqûre tous tu le gardes en
parlant une injection
c'est 3 euros 15 après vous avez en brut
1 donc c'est la moitié qui part aussi
dans les charges et un pour ceux qui
connaissent la profession libérale et
après vous avez le frais de déplacement
donc par exemple pour une objection on
va se déplacer pour cet euro c'est moins
cher qu'un plombier c'est pas cher payé
pour ce qu'on fait en fait il ya encore
des gens qui pensent que les infirmières
libérales sont riches oui parce que
quand on change chance arrête voiture
comme c'est notre outil premier ballon
change beaucoup de voitures on s'achète
des belles voitures parce qu'on a besoin
de confort parce qu'on est c'est notre
première maison en fait vous êtes toute
la journée on est toute la journée
dedans
on est dans les intempéries puis on doit
pouvoir aller partout on fait énormément
de kilomètres on peut faire autant qu'un
taxi des points il faut le savoir
pardon voilà
bonjour
bonne journée
alors on a donc les infirmières elles
font les la majorité 1
donc c'est chacun fait comme il l'entend
on fait des tests pca donc pour faire un
test pcr on a besoin de ce genre de
sachets avec double emballages 1 puisque
c'est pour sécuriser et donc on a
comment dirais-je fabriquer nous mêmes
nos blouses parce qu'on a eu un problème
de matériel et ben en fait quand on
fabrique les blues
eh bien on a des moments parce que on a
tous des mamans qui sont très inquiètes
pour nous et qui nous aident donc là
c'est on a fait des récoltes de draps et
on a fabriqué des surblouse pour aller
faire nos tests nos tests pcr
vous êtes quand même dans le système d
beaucoup et on a été obligé pour
récupérer des gants aussi actuellement
on a un problème pour récupérer les
gants parce qu'on utilise énormément de
gand et elle nous a fabriqué aussi des
calots que j'ai planqué je ne sais plus
où voilà donc les gens nous ont donné du
tissu on a fabriqué des cas loire les
calots c'est le petit chapeau qu'on met
sur la tête pour se couvrir
allez on me touche sa ceinture
les soignants mag le génial ne se pose
pas de questions ils avancent toujours
parce que le matin si on commence à se
poser des questions par rapport à notre
situation on n'y va pas parce que la
boule au ventre elle commençait la
trouille elle commence fait on a une vie
monacale parce qu'on ne fait que
travailler rentrer chez soi on peut plus
rien faire on fait nos courses comme on
peut parce qu'on travaille beaucoup en
rade le général on mange on dort et puis
on retourne travailler on n'a plus du
tout de vie sociale on n'a plus du tout
devis de vie normale moi ça fait quand
même deux mois et demi que je ne
retourne plus voir mes parents et on est
tout le temps dedans en fait on est
dedans à l'extérieur de dents dans le
travail et on est avec la misère des
gens les problèmes des gens et
on est tout le temps de temps c'est pour
ça que vous réclamez notamment un ségur
de oui et je veux dire là franchement
ils ont quand même intérêt à écouter les
soignants parce que là là là ça commence
à enfler dans l'est c'est une révolution
qui se prépare
on a prévenu on a envoyé des messages on
a interpellé on a on est passé dans les
médias on n'a pas écouté les gens de
terrain tous les administratifs tous les
tous les gens qui ont fait des grandes
écoles des énarques c'est tout ça qui
s'occupe de la santé
samson après le ministre de la santé
c'est un médecin mais je trouve que il
est plus dans le coup quoi ça fait trop
longtemps qu'il a quitté le milieu je
fais de la politique qui fait plus là il
fait plus il fait plus de la santé en
fait il est plus docteur il est un
politicien donc dans son comportement
ça peut pas aller quoi il ya que les
infirmières qui se comprennent un quant
à elle s'appelle se disent j'ai emballé
dix morts aujourd'hui c'est pas évident
vous savez un point deux soignantes de
faire que de l'emballage dans du
plastique parce que ben vous respectez
pas le cadre du soin l'humanité un de
pouvoir accompagner les gens quand vous
les ans dormait et qu' ils se
réveilleront plus il se met à pleurer
parce qu'ils feront pas il faut le vivre
ça je vous assure qu'il faut le vivre
allez-y c'est une vieille maison
moi je baisse les chaises vient la jet
bien il n'est pas méchant
alors vous préventive vous et des mamans
dans la gestion du coup vite dans cette
période un peu compliquée tout à fait
mais en fait deux fois par semaine je
l'accompagnais drive laboratoire et moi
je m'occupe de tout ce qui est
administrative et l'accueil des
personnes et est comme ça j'ai de ma
mère pour qu'elle évite en fait si vous
voulez de déshabiller se rhabiller sas a
permis en fait une fluidité dans les
tests
en réalité ce que vous faites vous aider
vous mettez la main à la pâte ça vous
est venu spontanément vous avez du
botteur notre coup réfléchir elles n'ont
pas du tout ne s'est pas posé de
questions d'accord mais vous faites quoi
dans la vie sinon je suis en master 2
planification et gestion des politiques
éducatives à l'international donc ces
sciences de l'éducation
d'accord c'est un peu compliqué en ce
moment d'aller au bout de son cursus
c'est très compliqué sachant que moi en
fait je devais avoir fini si vous voulez
en fait j'ai eu un prolongement d'années
et j'ai pas pu partir en stage je devais
partir en stage à l'étranger en
argentine et avec le co vident peu à ça
c'est annulé et c'est vraiment très très
compliqué de terminer l'année et c'est
surtout l'avenir pour nous les étudiants
qui nous inquiète beaucoup
vous lui avez votre maman ah oui
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est pas
facile tous les jours de vivre avec une
personne qui par tous les jours soigner
les personnes
et puis en plus les horaires qu'elle a
sont très très aléatoire mais depuis
qu'on est petit donc avec ma petite
soeur qui n'est pas là mais on est on
est habitués en fait on est baigné
dedans et vous voyez est maintenant
suivi parce que ma petite soeur elle a
choisi des études paramédicales aussi a
fait des études de kinésithérapeute
bref prenez votre muse on va faire la
photo dans la cuisine un qi ouais c'est
bien quand tu mets crus comme si
j'allais faire un pcr d'accord sur la
relève donc sur lunettes blues masques
ffp2 surblouse kahlo le père de ben
voilà c'est la totale
super voilà complètement équipé pour
affronter le virus
[Musique]